okay so this is the last module of last
set of lectures this quarter so
let's do a recap of logic so what have
we talked about
so we talked about logic during this
week we talked about three main
ingredients of logic we talked about
syntax which basically defines a set of
formulas allows us to syntactically
symbolically talk about formulas and
talk about things that exist in the
world so for example i might say rain
and wet without knowing what rain means
or what means or what this ant symbol
means and and that is in the syntax line
where i just like have symbols and i can
manipulate those symbols
and then i can assign meanings to the
syntax using semantics so the idea of
semantics is that for every formula you
can specify a set of models m of f which
is basically a set of assignments or
configurations in the world that assign
meaning to a formula a syntactic formula
f
so in the case of rain and width for
example rain can take values 0 and 1
when the wet can take values 0 and 1 and
then in the case of rain and width it
would be this darker area that
corresponds to the meaning of what does
it mean when both rain and red is true
okay
so in general when we try to define
logic we need both syntax and semantics
syntax as a symbol as a way of just
writing it out writing out the formula
semantics as a way of giving meaning to
those formulas and in addition to syntax
and semantics we talked about inference
rules we spent quite a bit of time
talking about modus ponens and
resolution for for both propositional
logic and first order logic as ways of
doing inference on our knowledge base so
we have a knowledge base which has a
bunch of formulas and the question is
what are some new formulas that we can
derive from that knowledge base for
example you might have rain and wet and
from that i can derive rain right like i
can actually derive and prove that it's
raining so how do we how do we think
about inference rules how can we infer
new new type of formulas here
and what can we tell about the formulas
that we infer so i think that is also an
interesting question that we have been
talking about so so how do we think
about inference algorithms so if you
have a knowledge base the idea is if we
have an inference rule like modus ponens
or resolution we should repeatedly apply
that inference rule until we get new
formulas and we derive new formulas new
f and as we get new formulas you're
expanding our knowledge base but we're
shrinking our the space of models
because we're adding more constraints if
i add a new formula in general and i'm
shrinking my space if i'm deriving a
formula though if that formula is just
derived from knowledge base it's not
it's not changing the size of my
knowledge base
so here is an example so let's say i
have wet and weekday and wet and weekday
implying traffic from these three
formulas in my premise what can i
conclude what can i infer so we talked
about modus ponens as an inference rule
that allows us to infer traffic out of
this okay
and then more more generally what does
modus ponens does and what does oneness
wants to modus points thinks about
having a set of propositional symbols p1
through pk
and then a formula that is p1 added
through pk implying q
and then it basically says we can derive
q that is what bonus modus ponens does
and then we basically talked about
soundness and completeness of of
inference rules for example modus ponens
as an example so what does soundness
mean soundness means that if you're
deriving things if you're deriving new
formulas you need to make sure that
these new formulas are actually true
they're actually they live in this space
of things that are entailed and are
actually true and and if you remember
our what our example with glass and
water inside of the glass what soundness
means is anything that we are deriving
should be inside of the glass it should
be a formula that's inside of the glass
because everything that's in glass is is
entailed and is true so we need to make
sure that everything that you're
deriving if you want to make sure it's
sound it has to be inside of the glass
on the other hand we talked about
completeness and completeness means that
we are deriving the whole truth meaning
that if i have this class i should be
able to derive everything that's that is
inside of this class or even more that
that is what completeness means okay
and if i have both soundness and
completeness then derivation and
entailment are basically the same thing
right like remember entailment is is is
about about meanings about semantics
right entailment is is about what what
is the meaning of f actually being
entailed by the knowledge base or being
contradicted by the knowledge base but
derivation is is just basically symbol
manipulation okay so
so it's difficult to talk about
entailment kind of in the semantics land
because you have to think about meanings
and so on but if you can do derivation
in in in the world of syntax you're just
moving around formulas and and kind of
mindlessly by moving around formulas and
applying inference rules you can derive
new formulas and and that allows you to
have a compact way of thinking about
these formulas and new formulas that are
being derived so if derivation is the
same thing as entailment that's pretty
nice because if if you have a virtual
assistant and you want to ask a virtual
assistant a question or maybe you want
to tell it some information that
corresponds to maybe an entailment
question and that might be difficult to
answer so instead if you have a sound
and complete inference rule for your for
your logic then maybe you can just check
derivation and derivation alone is going
to is going to give you the answer okay
so that is why we talked about
derivation for a bit
and we discussed modus ponens um for
propositional logic and the fact that
modus ponens is actually sound for
propositional logic but it is not
complete it's not able to get all the
formulas that are true
so in order to solve that we had two
solutions one was maybe propositional
logic is too large maybe we should
reduce the size of propositional logic
and then the other idea was maybe modus
ponens is not as strong maybe we should
make modus ponens stronger or come up
with a stronger inference rule so let's
talk about those two ideas the first
idea is propositional logic allows us to
talk about any legal combination of
symbols and and that is pretty
expressive but maybe that is too
expressive so maybe we can just look at
propositional logic with only horn
clauses so this is a restricted set of
logic formulas and that allows us
to to basically have this more
restricted set and that allows us to get
both soundness and completeness with
modus ponens so what is a horn clause
horn clause is basically a clause that
has at most one positive literal so if
you write this in the cnn form in the
conjunctive normal form then you want to
basically make sure that you have at
most one positive literal another way of
writing it is that you have you have an
end of a set of propositional symbols p1
added through pk and that implies some
sum q and you basically want to make
sure that there are no no ores here or
no branchings here that that is why
we could actually show
completeness with horn clauses
all right so
that was basically propositional logic
uh
with horn clauses using modus ponens and
that gives us completeness okay without
we the general propositional logic
doesn't give us completeness with more
response the other option we discussed
is is maybe we should have a fancier
inference rule specifically resolution
was the thing that we started looking at
so resolution was able to give us both
soundness and completeness the issue
with it was uh it was it was actually
exponential time as opposed to linear
time and when we think about modus
ponens where we keep adding only one
formula and at most like we'll end up
with n formulas but with resolution we
might have an exponential time algorithm
but we end up getting both soundness and
completeness which is nice
okay so that was all about prepositional
logic at some point we started talking
about first order logic so we started
expanding our logic and try to be more
expressive in our logic try to be able
to talk about variables talk about uh
quantifiers and and be able to have a
better way of representing things that
are much harder to represent in
propositional logic and then we started
talking about syntax semantics and
inference rules for for first order
logic so so basically we went over the
same things for first order logic so
comparing propositional logic with first
order logic in propositional logic we
have this option of doing model checking
when we think about our models and and
the semantics of our models in first
order logic we don't really have an
analog of that but we have this other
thing called propositionalization so for
subset of first order logic uh formulas
what we can do is we can do
propositionalization and that takes us
back back to the propositional logic
land and we can use the same tools that
are there
thinking about inference rules we
discussed modus ponens with horn clauses
and the fact that it sound incomplete
same story is true with first order
logic so we could apply modus ponens
with horn clauses in first order logic
it's sound and complete there's a plus
plus here and that plus plus basically
means that we had to change modus ponens
a little bit so we discussed unification
and substitution because we have
variables here so because there are
those variables you should be able to we
should we should apply unification and
substitution to make sure that our modus
ponens makes sense in the space of first
order logic
similarly we discussed resolution and
then it showed that it is general and
it's sound and complete in propositional
logic and in the case of first order
logic we briefly discussed this in an
optional uh module and again like this
is resolution plus plus because we are
talking about applying unification and
and substitution on resolution too and
again it sounded complete even under
first order logic which is kind of nice
all right so that summarizes our logic
lecture i just want to like leave you
guys with one thought when you think
about logic
so so what is it about logic that is
useful again
we talked about all the all the
limitations of it right the fact that it
can't handle uncertainty or it's not
probabilistic really or it's pretty
brittle it doesn't it's not able to
capture data as you get more data it's
hard to update its rules because it has
all these deterministic rules that are
built on top of each other
but it does have one big benefit and
that one big benefit is that it allows
us to have a very compact and concise
way of representing knowledge that we
wouldn't normally have right like
remember like the whole point of
inference rules was i had this logical
formula which is like a very compact way
of thinking about semantics and
knowledge that's actually pretty
difficult to represent in the semantics
land and now that i have this concise
formula i can just manipulate it i can
move it around and i can do all sorts of
inference rules on top of it i can come
up with new formulas derive new formulas
and prove new formulas and that's pretty
interesting and it's much harder to do
that in the semantics line so the thing
that logic really gives us it's really
like big strength here is having this
compact representation that can help us
think better about about about formulas
and and do better manipulation of them
and i think one thing that would be very
interesting to think about is how could
we use these ideas maybe not exactly
logic but ideas from logic in some of
the more modern ai systems some of the
more modern machine learning based
systems and and i think that is a pretty
interesting view of logic that that
would be good to take from this class
you